That's something secret. Okay. We all
know who wrote that. So when who wrote
you compiled it all? No. No. You don't
know. When is what is the earliest copy
of
the excellent copy?
Oral tradition. 13th century. 13 11th
century. I think it's Leningrad Codex if
I remember correctly. Okay. Yeah. Okay.
So that's after Islam. It's oral
tradition though. So all the oral
tradition came before. No, but the oral
tradition was meant to be written down
before Islam. Again, just because we had
the
early debate. No, but if you want to
establish that it's it's correct, you
need to a way to substantiate it. You
can't do it through manuscript. Huh?
Because you're saying God God is pleased
with the rabbis uh legislating their law
and God is ple Yeah. You're you're when
it when it says, for example, smash the
baby's head against the rock. If I'm
before I smash a if I'm a rabbitic Jew
and if I'm a rabbitic Jew and I'm going
to smash a baby's head against the law,
I want to know that that's from God's
saying the Torah. Smash smash the baby's
head against the rock and say the Torah
says in Psalms in Psalms. Yeah. Yes.
That's not the rabbi. No, no, no, no,
no, no. I'm talking about all of the
rabbi. Hang on. I'm talking about all of
the law. I'm including the all and the
written. Are you an orthodox Jew? No.
Why does it matter to you? I'll tell you
why. Because when I see somebody about
to smash the head of a baby against the
rock, okay, like you can stop and and
and they tell me that we have
religious baby. You can stop. I'm seeing
it happen in Gaza and I'm stopping them.
That's what I'm doing now. Now talking
to me. Yeah. Okay. Now you're the one
that's justifying Israel's actions in
Gaza. Are you stopping them? I'm I'm
mentioning what I'm saying. Okay, great.
Yeah. Okay. So when I see somebody about
to smash a baby's head against a rock
believing he has religious
justification hang on hang on hang on
hang on hang on if I'm hypothetical
situation there's we can't think of any
situation where we see uh people doing
it in the name of Hang on you're cutting
me now you can't see any situation where
because you're repeating the same
nonsense you're not letting me finish
you're not letting me finish you you
don't like this subject that's what it
is so let me just finish the point my
point is that's fine I'm stupid to you
because of the stupid because I'm a or
what the subject then that's fine. Hear
the subject then.
Absolutely. Absolutely. So when I'm
seeing a person smashed the head of a
baby against a rock and he believes he
has religious justification for it and I
ask him to where is your chain of
transmission for how do you know that
this is from God? How do you know this
is from David or how do you know that's
from Moses? And he tells me ah we have a
chain of transmission in the Talmud.
This was just passed down from from my
rabbis. That's what I'm picking up.
That's what I want to show. Hang on. the
rabbis entered something. You you
mentioned Rabbi Mir earlier. There's a
narration that mentions anything that
has no uh no no source attributed to
Rabbi Mir. Anything that has no source,
if you want it to stick, attribute it to
Rabbi Mir. So when you said, "Yeah, we
know Rabbi Hannasai. He's the one who
compiled this.